[Music]
welcome to n World America's favorite
vacation destination I'm
Cappy oh and I'm bottle and we're here
to make sure you have fun fun during
your time at the
park be the cheer cheeriest place in all
the world where the river's made of
quantum and mountain tops are f with and
for all the moms and pops and kid buts
out there's a place
with come on down to world and see it
for ADV ofal to
see gtic Z for other thrill to dry Rock
and live the world of refresh the most
wonderful place the friendly streets of
Nu town a smile on your face now you
know there's a place that's just as
great as
n come on down to n world and see it for
yourself anation that refres a tri you
won forget a par with them the of the C
when your thirst for adventure
[Applause]
new